[Music]
and the beads and the powers in the
priests of your up your knees and bow
there is a tree house in the meadow
below the mountain peak the perfect
place when they play hide and seek
there's a covered bridge at [ __ ]
Creek where the horses always stop mean
it'd be house and the gutter it's rich
that's how
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the bees on the flowers and the bees
did erupt your knees in love there are
roses on the trellis and the 71 hate the
clinging vine is jealous on the fence
across the wind there's a great big
bazinga song the roses and the yellow
face
[Music]
the birds and the bees and the flowers
and the bees - you're up to your knees
in
[Music]
Lord's the gonna not again
howdy Drago surely makes seven times
this month he come home swag oh six
seven six once was his birthday they
don't count him in the bucket them
didn't have anything for breakfast for
two row eggs and the mother honey
no Carly yes boss don't say it's a fine
morning or I'll shoot you
get out of here fighting in the morning
Karlis what are you doing up there I
hope I get this time mr. McLintock my
brothers they got the big hats already
alright let them have at it you promised
me you would
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you got cattle in the back boss
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Kim goin 15 cents a pound all the way to
Kansas City
[Music]
now boss there's one old pensioner I
wished you would pass up bunny yeah
nowhere I'd seen his face before no time
he's just been around town a couple
years oh you have no milk of human
kindness Clinic morning bunny Harry you
see you're in good health never felt
better
contrary to what you may hear me the
kidneys ain't what they used to be
English livers believing me Millie's
Drago hello Ben
a Matt Rennick they go throw that in the
buggy yes sir this grubby bunch of
Sooners huh they are that I gotta make
Douglas happy finding his pockets with
land fees what are we gonna do I don't
know what you're gonna do Ben me I do
nothing
200 families quarter of beef a week for
family they last two years that can be a
sizable number I got 20 had one of any
other brand on the Mesa Verde I'm not
hauling some of us haven't got all the
money in the world some of us ain't old
and tired and feel like being put upon
you interest me young Ben go on so the
first time I find one of our hides
wearing our brand hung on one of them
settlers fences
I aim to kill me a plow boy you do what
you want my clinic we'll do what we want
fellas my age generally call me GW or
McClintock youngsters call me mr.
McClintock
all right mr. McLintock not because I'm
afraid of the Big East out of this
country
and I reckon a fellow my age should call
you mr. wrong now GW he's a half owner
to spread I made him a full partner
today the doc gave me the long face well
you want him to both the first time this
territory becomes a state don't you of
course I do these settlers get burned
out there will be a lot of hollering
that this country's too while to be a
state will go on being a territory some
more with a lot of political appointees
run and then according to what they
learned in some college where they think
that cows are something you milk Indians
are some in front of a cigar store I'm
looking to use old young man down
I'll do what I can mono at the house
once in a while will rack up a few hands
is done he never that'll be just fine
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a nice morning any boss everybody's
entitled to their own opinion I like
that again a it's something to cheer you
about a thousand hit I figured I'll
bring about 1250 you're not as fat as
I'd like this ship sail off the North
range yes
[Music]
settlers every one of them with a plow
and a Bible
not the slightest idea but arranges for
[Music]
I'm a clinic you people planned a
homestead and farmed the Mesa Verde yes
sir the government give us each hundred
and sixty acres the government never
gave anybody anything
some years back a lot like you came in
got a pretty good first year good summer
easy winter but the next year the last
rain was in February and by June even
the Jackrabbits had sense enough to get
off the Mesa folks do you know who that
is
that's McClintock George Washington
McLintock I told him that Douglas he
controls the water rights on two hundred
square miles of range you know that
lumber you got it cape miss land cut by
his lovers and milled in his Mills
Douglas I come close to killing you a
couple of times when we were younger
saddens me I didn't can you imagine a
man holds all that oh and mines - I
forgot to mention them all that and he's
begrudging poor people a measly of
measly 160 acres that right mr.
McClintock you begrudge us a little free
land there's no such thing as
real and you make these homesteads go
you'll have earned every acre of it but
you just can't make them go on the Mesa
Verde God made that country for Buffalo
serves pretty well for cattle but it
hates the plough and even the government
should know that you can't farm 6,000
feet above sea level any trouble mr.
McClintock no trouble Jeff how about you
Douglas Douglas just plain Douglas and
you call here mr. McClintock why well
Douglas I guess it's because he earned
it
mr. McLintock yeah I'm a good hand with
cattle mr. McLintock like a job
well you look strong enough you come in
with our sewers well yes sir but we
don't have a homestead dad you you
apply paint it sunny Haley but future
being a farmer on these parts
[Music]
ladies this is the finest Chantilly lace
available anywhere jean te mr. Birnbaum
well believe me it's the best oh excuse
me please look around take your time
Drago I got a thousand Havana cigars in
12 those hatch for you over there
they're big hats hang on last long the
way some folks have been different into
that red eye these days
good morning GW good morning I stole
some stick candy please help yourself
come on problem yes well by our blacks
that move Queens Bishop to King four
yeah you might be right
you know just starting to work this out
when the letter came letter don't you
love it
morning mr. McLintock morning Davey you
being here save me a trip
oh that Hatton suit of clothes you
picked out for my birthday well instead
of this cowboy hat I'd like to have this
one if it's all right with you sir oh
that's all right with me Davey of course
that looks like the kind of ahead of
fellow Edward on Main Street to start a
fight oh I don't need a city hat for
that all I have to do is walk down the
street and some wiseacre will call me an
Indian and just like that the fights on
Davey the letter it's for you and you
are an Indian yes I know I'm an Indian
but I'm also the fastest runner in town
I've got a college education and I'm the
railroad telegrapher but does anybody
say hello college man or hello runner or
hello telegrapher no not even hello not
head baby it's always let the Indian do
it you go out in the store and help the
ladies all right I'm also bookkeeper
part-time clerk lady brought that out
here this morning asked for it to be
taken out to the home ranch for you
handsome lady kind of tall with red hair
called me mr. Birnbaum just as if she'd
never seen me before and as if that veil
had covered a face to keep me from
recognizing
I thought she was in New York or Europe
or someplace solenoid Jake you better
throw on a couple extra cases the boss's
favorite bourbon that stuff sure gets
used up fast out of our place which
reminds me
you better start tapering off yeah
Catherines in town Katie
[Music]
good morning morning father I want you w
you doing in here why aren't you out at
the desk have a knife - bartender yeah I
see a busy day give me the key to room
17 what 17 and don't advertise it beer
whiskey day off off day wonder what he's
so preoccupied about haven't you heard
no what
Katie's back in town Katie yes dear the
social audit ooh yeah hi honey
good morning mr. McLintock I don't want
to bother you I'm sorry boy I told you
no job
[Music]
Catherine George Washington
[Music]
I thought you'd want this
first dig of this Berk but who am I to
upset your plans did you feel kind of
silly
I never feel silly it's because you have
no sense of humor
why couldn't we sit down in the hotel
dining room and talk about whatever it
is you want to talk about our why
couldn't you just come over to the house
I'd have everybody know that we're
meeting everybody knows and what's the
difference we're married that is
something I should like to change you
know the answer
Katie that isn't why you sent for me
let's get to the rat killer that's just
the kind of remark that's always indeed
you to me let us open the discussion
very well
our daughter is coming home in a few
days Rob she's coming here it was just a
slip of the tongue that made me refer to
this ugly Hamlet as home our daughter is
it so hard to say her name it's Becky
Rebecca I hate that name anyway she's
coming home and I hope to persuade you
to let her live with me part of the time
in the capital part of the time in New
York and of course Newport during the
season
you're whistling in the wind okay if she
stays here just as crude and his vulgar
as all he's kind of she goes your way
she'll be all show I know stay no go
Kate oh how I hate you half the people
in the world are women why does it have
to be you that's dirty
[Music]
that's the story I saw your picture in
the paper at the Governor's Ball you
were dancing with a governor at a
Steeler jet I doubt that you have to be
a man first before you're a gentleman he
misses on both counts
[Music]
hey Sonny
nope hey boy do you get a pocket your
pride
you got a babe you better listen to an
expert honey I'm telling you got to grow
human nature get some every time mister
leave me alone everybody done it one way
or another about that job in the clinic
I already told you son I've got no need
for farmers are used for him just one
minute mr. McLintock my father died last
month that's how come we lost our
homestead I've got a mother and a little
sister to feed I need that job badly
what's your name Devlin Warren you got a
job son see my home ranch farm and he's
over at the corral step down off of that
carriage mister I've been punched many a
time in my life but never for hiring
anybody I don't know what to say
never faked before turn my stomach I
suppose I should have been grateful you
gave me the job gave why you got it all
wrong I don't give jobs I hire men you
intend to give this man a full day's
work don't you boy you mean you're still
hiring me mr. macclay well yes sir I
mean I'll certainly deliver a fair day's
work for that I'll pay you a fair day's
wage you won't give me anything and I
won't give you anything we both hold up
our heads where do you live the settlers
encampment down by the mine
that's your plug yes sir well hop on him
and we'll go get your gear
[Music]
[Music]
morning boy
[Music]
I am sure that all you find people are
interested in knowing just what portion
of this new land will be your new home
Oh Jones and McAlister since you've been
more or less the leaders of our group
I'd like to have you come up and check
the exact location go after that boy and
give him $30 tell him my clinic pays
these riders a month in advance the
looks of things I could sure use it to
Oh mom it's mr. Drago well what do we
owe this visit from the cattle baron I'm
gonna touch a hangover a bureaucrat
don't push me Indians in this homestead
land friendly Indians my boy Oh get
drunk together and it's gonna be a lot
longer time because it's against the law
and you're with a sheriff and if I got
my hands full they came into town to
meet the train the old Indian chiefs are
coming home I heard they'd been pardoned
they don't know when it's arriving this
week next week or next month so in the
meantime I've got to do something with
them did I cut out a couple ahead of
your steers to feed them otherwise some
of these settlers milk cows are gonna
disappear
that's right Macklin shut out whatever
you need sheriff are you gonna camp
these savages with all these settlers
you're asking for trouble mr. Douglass I
already have plenty of trouble please
stay off my back
Benin Pablo bring your people over to
the place live
mr. Macklin tiny mouth it's nice to see
you you wouldn't believe it now but 20
years ago she was a mighty handsome made
20 years ago you thought so too mr.
Douglas it was just like this I had a
deadbeat on old running Buffalo my sharp
50 caliber misfired as bagging that
trouble in the forest remember I
remember eight you won't do something
come directly from him yeah
we should get this boys mama baked up
you thinking the same thing I am
she's a widow woman Boston she's got a
long hard road IRA I always said you had
a deeper sense mr. McLintock is my
mother
your mother and my sister pleased to
meet you mr. McLintock ma'am this is my
Boston he has few choice words to say
about your biscuits
yes mr. McLintock they're great well you
old can these reprobate how about it why
me I cut myself I'm not talking about
firing ya I'm retired yeah you've been
rustling food for us for 30 years
we're gonna put you out to pasture all
you'll have to do is give advice be one
of the family I tell myself I may save
you the trouble
Ching you kill yourself I'll cut off
your pigtail you never gonna get to
heaven I'll be one of her family I give
you my solemn word could you call me
family drink too much ease get in Phase
II yell all the time cut off his pigtail
oh I don't I'll be wonderful Fanny yeah
I hope everything is satisfactory this
is such a big house it'll take me a
while to get used to things now please
don't hesitate to tell me if anything is
wrong no business I'll go by just fine
everything nicely my best apple pie ever
at Curly's right ma'am hated to leave
that last bite
shall we celebrate with a drink use all
them clothes you keep a civil tongue in
your unprepossessing face yes ma'am and
unload my baggage please yes ma'am
by the way what does that word
unprepossessing mean miss McClintock oh
hello
run and help the driver with my luggage
I couldn't trust anyone else in this
house to do anything correctly luggage
give him a hand
curly yes boss are you moving back in
yes but nothing has changed except my
place of residence and I'd be willing to
put up with savages rather than be
denied the company of my daughter and
I'm proving that by moving in here mr.
McLintock since it's my first day would
you excuse me if I go ahead Oh Catherine
this is dev Warren you joined the outfit
today please ma'am thank you Wow how
refreshing a polite young man here where
did he come from
he's a farmer oh gee welcome home what
on earth are you doing in that idiotic
looking outfit don't you dare call me
Kate abutment Sudan
for the boss and I'm sorry Katherine
that Kate kind of slipped out from the
times I remembered us being nice big
people you gonna stand there with that
stupid look on your face while the hired
help insult your wife he's just ignorant
he doesn't know any better than to tell
the truth and I can't help this stupid
look I started acquiring it as you
gained in social prominence
mrs. McClendon where do you want I
should put him in the master bedroom yes
but move mr. mclintock's things into
another room Oh back of the stairs would
be best so that he can't wake up the
entire household just before daybreak
yes ma'am excuse me here's your cigars
mr. McLintock I am mrs. McLintock Kate I
mean Katherine
this is the cook this the lady doesn't
cook it for us mrs. Warren mrs.
McLintock hi very pleased to meet you
mrs. McLintock very pleased
likewise you see I just came to work
here today and I guess I jumped to the
conclusion that this was a bachelor's
household hmm it is and then again it
isn't I will explain so everything will
be quite clear mrs. Wallace
[Music]
mrs. Warren it has been a bachelor's
household for quite some time
and it will be again just as soon as I
am out of here
which would be as quickly as I can make
arrangements to take my daughter back
east with me you see she's coming home
from school in a few days and then we'd
be off together and you can return to
conducting yourself as you consider
proper in a bachelor's household Katie
shut up until then I am mistress in this
house
and I will give the orders say nothing
boss oh and GW as soon as my things are
put away I want to talk to you about
Rebecca
yes mrs. McLintock candy a toast lightly
browned and unbuttered of course ma'am
[Music]
where you think you're going I just
remembered I got a date but she said she
won't to have a talk I heard
[Music]
good evening ma'am
evening mr. Mack yep hey mr. Mack what
is unprepossessing mean I was called
that one slim looked it up in the
dictionary it's best you don't know what
at me uh-huh
thank you you would expect that from you
anyway
first mr. McClintock gone there you go
burning his last bridge you see a yellow
streak about a foot wide running up down
his backbone mr. McLintock he ain't
afraid of nothing
I once thought that
Drago yes ma'am what's that he took off
lit out I told him I wanted to talk to
us ma'am I was standing right over here
when you said it and I was standing
right on those front steps when he
walked up to a horse grabbed a hunk I
mean stepped up on him and sucks burg
where did he go last time I saw him he's
going east but you know him he's allowed
to go north south or west
get me a couch yes ma'am but but what
maybe you shouldn't follow him and maybe
where he's going into what does that
mean I wish I hadn't said it I'll just
get the carriage yes ma'am
what happened
it's a Bruce Bruce get up she wants to
go to town but mr. McLintock never said
anything to me about look young fella
I'm not right I'm the ramrod around this
place you better start giving me yes sir
you gonna get the roof of this house
pull down on your head yes sir
[Applause]
[Music]
hello bunny how is everything
Oh fine fine mr. McLintock I'll get you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what'll it be Mac same as usual
lady evening to you w Jake wrong move
flat-chest problem queens in danger
[Music]
Camille you're on your own there's no
play I'm Camille give me a read bottom
I'm learning the game of chess
mmm thought would give me something pass
the time see I have nothing to do all
day long just remembered something
Catherine I didn't hear you come in mr.
McLintock I told you that I wanted to
talk to you not now could I get you a
glass of sherry Catherine oh thank you
mr. Birnbaum I could use one I came into
town behind a runaway team girl never
could handle horses that young man whose
mother pretends to be your cook
Catherine your wine oh thank you mr.
Birnbaum now mr. McLintock we have an
awful lot to talk over first thing I
learned about Indian fighting was to
wait for daylight
what is our conversation got to do with
Indian fighting Indian fighting is good
experience for our kind of conversations
oh it'll wait Catherine indeed Sarah mr.
McClintock we had quite a ride out here
oh I finally got that team settle down
sure moved no it's your move I just cast
off oh look here you're not gonna sit
here all night long and play chess when
the matter of our daughter remains
unsettled I am gonna remain here in play
chess no matter of our daughter is
settled she stays
Catherine your hair oh he's a mess after
that awful ride no no it's just that I
haven't seen you for a long time and it
seems to me the last time I saw you your
hair was a little darker no it's a funny
thing that tricks a man's memory will
player mr. Birnbaum I think that you've
completely lost your mind
you have done something to your hair
myself at the places that those blondie
crops that you seem to prefer take it Oh
fill it Oh
[Music]
if I must I let it all night McLintock
never quits but a Birnbaum has to
besides the game is over you got me
no mr. Birnbaum you still got a good
game oh you play chess please take up
[Music]
pretty good fair looks like I'm gonna
have to come into town always to get a
game remember I'm a bad loser your move
yes
[Music]
[Music]
good morning cup of coffee oh yes thanks
Jake
[Music]
you're welcome Catherine
[Music]
got any cream can cows Moo
good old condensed milk that reminds me
I was cleaning out my desk the other day
I found something I wanted to return to
you here it is
[Music]
it's a medal remember from the president
of the United States of America the
First Sergeant Michael Patrick you lowly
while bravery above and beyond the call
of duty
it's your papa reminds me of the first
time I ever saw you was over 17 years
ago walked into my store not much bigger
than the bundle you were carrying and in
the bundle was the most beautiful baby I
ever saw and was she hungry walked all
the way from superstition Creek just to
trade me that medal for a Kasich and
Nick GW was off somewhere as usual
fighting Indians looks like burn bonds
is open so there you are chef I told you
you were headed for trouble trouble I
wanna know by whose authority you let
those Indians stay in town no savages
are Ward's of the government and I am
the representative of that old Sheriff
Lord that he could put him up down with
a clay side because the town's named
after him he thinks he owns it well you
check the books and the recorders office
and you'll find I do own a fair piece of
it a guard if you knew anything about
Indians you know that they're doing
their level best to put up with our
so-called benevolent patronage in spite
of a nincompoop that have been put in
charge of it those endings need my
permission to leave the reservation
those Chiefs have been giving orders all
their lives it's pretty hard for them to
understand that they have to hold up
their hand like a schoolboy in the
classroom now law is very clear I told
you you'd get no satisfaction from these
people well we'll get the girl back girl
the girly Indians kidnapped but don't
worry I armed the settlers and set them
to rounding up those Red Devils what is
this about a girl Milly Jones one of the
settlers daughters and ins kidnapped her
that's ridiculous
and you turn loose a lot of farmers with
shotguns I certainly
you're insane let's go Sheriff mr.
Douglas Oh miss McClintock much as I
hate to agree with GW about anything you
haven't changed a bit
you're still an hysterical fool maybe
Katie shot you
not yet Drago but it took restraint
[Music]
will you stop showing off and getting
this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just where do you think you're going
don't use that rain boss
tone of voice with me
[Music]
mr. war boys mine bout up some riders
bye boss
I don't like it mr. McLintock I don't
like it one bit what don't you like
they're planning to hang an Indian
[Music]
funny whiskey all right you're so fast
mr. boss of the whole country unless you
want to wear a big hole in your middle
how long is GW gonna let that cheat
Chalker push him around that cheat
sucker has a sawed-off shotgun how do
you know she didn't wander off someplace
or meet some fellers what are you saying
that I didn't raise my girl right that
she'd wander off all night with some man
there's a lot of things I'm not saying
to you mister well you got a sawed-off
shotgun in my middle but how do you know
this Indian had anything to do with it
she's gone and she's gone
[Music]
[Music]
young man took me for a sunrise ride and
the horse wandered away clinic we
weren't doing nothing but that's not
important right now important thing is
that you don't draw that hog leg here
this will be worse in Dodge City on
Saturday night I'll tend to you later
this young whippersnapper how no harm
has been done young man here is one of
the nicest boys in the territory so just
put down that shotgun oh he had a
full-width Mike
No we'll all calm down she's just a
little excited I know I know I'm gonna
use good judgment I haven't lost my
temper in 40 years but pilgrim you
caused a lot of trouble this morning
might have got somebody killed and
somebody oughta belt you in the mouth
but I won't
I will the hell I will the cranek Rider
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
nice party
[Music]
do you think you are high or don't what
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
yeah very funny
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. Boddy you big
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well
[Applause]
[Music]
where is everybody for heaven sakes
[Music]
my family your pigtail I lose face lose
more nad hey yes we could be a big help
to one another like what may I ask
oh we could wash the mud off of each
other we used to have quite good times
doing that sort of li there are a lot of
things we used to do good luck
what are you talking about I mean
divorce
she's still wanted yeah you know
something women are funny she fought
like a wildcat on your side out there is
that come home she slams the door in
your face that divorce business is that
what you get when you pay a woman not to
live with you it's about it some women
I've noted be worth it you know if we
had any moral character we wouldn't be
standing here covered with mud drinking
when we should be washing GW Drago
[Music]
Thank You Drago good morning mrs. Warren
morning mr. McLintock breakfast for the
boss if that's the way you want it mr.
McLintock
[Music]
one poached a tea toast lightly browned
and on why mrs. McLintock you have a
black eye I do
oh he's coming home today that's not all
there's a little something we'd better
get settled
hmm there are no men listening now so we
can be ourselves oh sure I let you get
away with all that guff the other night
but now that we're alone when I want the
opinion of the hired help I'll ask for
it
you know you could wind up with two
black eyes what oh I realize you had to
put on that big act we always have to
just before we get ready to forgive them
generally for something they haven't
done but you and I both know that's just
to keep them from getting the idea they
run things
McLintock give you that black eye No
nobody gave it to me I want
[Music]
morning mrs. beach mr. Beach
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I guess I'm gonna have to stop calling
you tomboy sure you do I've been here a
few days thank you I brought you three
of the most beautiful dresses did you
bring your uncle coming home present
sure did what is it mustache Cup what
did you get me prettiest ballerina Pony
that ever practiced Anna broke the stand
round tie in together had a little
accident
I brought you a whole shipment licorice
sticks but now that I've seen how much
you've grown
I think we better exchange him for a
couple of bolts address good
oh the Mayor was gonna be here but he
had to go to the territorial capital on
a horse theft matter but I'm gonna give
his speech
don't worry I'm sure that he can find a
bill of sale for the horse ladies and
gentlemen we are here to welcome the
fairest what am i doing we are here to
welcome back the prettiest girl that was
ever born in McClintock or in any part
of the territory
Hey damn right so I like them in here
I've had my scalp a long time and I aim
to keep it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and now she's come back to us
gone are the pigtails but the freckles
are still on the prettiest face that was
ever born in McClintock
hey that's Puma and it's true the
government did turn to look good oh I'll
never forget
we brought GW your father holding his
Chester
a hundred and four fever of course they
weren't very mad at me about it
it came past the house at a high lope
throw him on the doorstep and you do
remember them good old days don't you
Katie
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
got to hey my friends Puma honored enemy
Darce big McLintock forget but also
blood brother and I'll never forget that
Oh does it hurt still hey feel it when
it comes on the rain the entire and I
wouldn't have to worry our feet
McLintock that was remembered fire we
return with news our people have more
trouble
you see I learned good English now
people Cleveland learned in white man's
jail but we would have you talk our
course at government hearing I
understand that governor Humphries is
gonna preside at that meeting
yes Puma I'll translate your wishes mr.
McLintock
could I impose on you to use your
Comanche to tell these chief of the
Comanches and he speaks English very
well oh well your people will have to
follow my instructions to the letter it
is the law of the left well now just a
minute for heaven sakes
[Music]
when I see you that best chorus taping
you can have that first day yes don't
want any sister of mine talking to
strangers
[Music]
darn you Drago
now look what you've done
baby this is devaron warm he works for
you papa there this is Miss Becky
McClintock
those are my things yes ma'am
oh I don't know anywhere miss Becky what
do you mean oh I mean you look so much
like your mother
we even prettier Oh mr. Warren love is
much prettier than I am many a fight
started with words like we got jelly pie
for dinner I'm not cooking no he's not
jr. yes miss Becky you remember jr.
Douglas mama
oh of course how's College valedictorian
95 congratulations
Oh mr. mrs. Douglas we will see you at
the party of course Oh Eli here well
it'll be pretty hard to keep young man
away yes GW you remember young jr. oh
yes like father like son
oh I'm missing McLintock I hope you
don't think I'm being presumptuous and
asking for the honor of calling on Miss
Rebecca well there she is ask you
yourself well thank you sir Jean now I'm
gonna get fired get up out of here thank
you sir thank you
yeah yeah yeah what like father like son
[Music]
[Music]
when you're finished there go over and
help drago with the beer cakes yes mom
could you come and help me a minute I
[Music]
certainly was surprised here you went to
college why I don't know junior says
produce a good college for a backwater
place like Indiana he did indeed how
could you do this I can't reach it
why don't you finish college lack of
funds
my father got sick he had to come out
west so he took out a homestead you know
your mom sure cute it's a too bad you
didn't inherit her eyes
well you'd been lucky if you'd inherited
a few things from your father oh really
for instance it's common sense for
instance common sense yeah you don't see
him being fooled by some dude like jr.
Douglas juniors not a dude he's nifty
his needs a woman's touch besides he got
a letter at college what sport glee club
very strenuous I have no intention of
hugging you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies all of the lovely Catherine know
this is a real fine party oh thank you
Ben of course we had to invite everybody
[Music]
well thank you mrs. Warren I guess I'll
have to be a good host my own home
[Music]
[Music]
Drako don't do what I told you to do
oh hey Catherine and do as you're told
Trey go do this ray go people people
people
this Douglas feller right oh yes ma'am
Matt Douglas jr. he's going to bring you
folks I'm the ladies terpsichorean dance
steps brand-new brought by him directly
from New York City
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
give me a whisper one time boy what
just turn it 10 gone potty boss well run
out of whiskey
oh I can take care of
[Music]
[Music]
and you still got any ideas about asking
my sister to dance get up and we can do
this all over again yes look you're
falling Farage square I don't think it
was so fair and square well you want to
take up where he left off if I did you
wouldn't find it so easy
this morning you're gonna quit walking
away just as soon as we're on his side
of the party the lesson I learned back
home don't fight in front of women oh
we're out of sight now so we are such
vulgarity someone should do something
about it
you're right absolutely right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you all right young man I'm all right
mr. McLintock
pretty fancy fighting for a country boy
two years at Purdue mr. McLintock on the
boxing game I never thought any farmer
could whip me juice sure did
they're getting cleaned up get him some
water Jake yeah
[Music]
[Music]
get yourself cleaned up go ask that girl
for a dance crazy GW oh so you're the
young farmer boy that whipped my nephew
well I'm font Leroy I say John Banzhaf
well I'm no farmer but if you're young
Ben's uncle yes I've whipped him and
you're intruding
what's intruding mean bud nin oh so he's
insulting me well then I got another
reason for walloping besides on the
county impression my nephew young bands
lover oh you can't get mixed up in these
youngsters quarrel family honor I can't
have set a farmer whipped a sage you're
twice his size
don't let that bother you mr. McLintock
mr. Fauntleroy insists I'll just have to
teach him the same lesson
[Applause]
[Music]
sorry young feller hate to have to do
that young fella no hard feelings
not yet not yet what I mean that isn't
all now wait a minute
fontleroy we're gonna make this a fair
fight course we are course we are GW all
be none of this you wouldn't do I don't
want you kicking Fauntleroy in the knee
and none of this knows twisty he's all
yours
[Applause]
you just bodied me but I want you to
know that boy fought me a fair fight
well I'm glad to hear that Tyler I my
uncle boy what are you been going out my
uncle didn't bother anybody
no bother I think we'd better join the
ladies before they get curious Drago pon
Rohit let's line them all up don't see
go Jake you think tincture of arnica
would help could be used to help you
gentlemen to the medicine cabinet
[Music]
murder this more than the scattegories
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll get you out so early something I
have to get straight in my mind yeah
what mama why'd you and mama stop living
together daddy why'd you separate aren't
you gonna answer me no it's sort of my
business I think I don't is it another
woman usually is at your age you always
know what's usual mrs. Warren Becky I
don't want to start laying the law down
your first day back home but I'll have
no more such talk first time I ever saw
mrs. Warren was last week she has a job
here at which she's very good I hope
you'll have the good manners to not pry
into other people's business your
mother's in mine pretty good shot daddy
oh I can understand your trouble
Mama's often so well so petulant
petulant you learned a lot of words
baggies Becky wish to God they too
touches some meanings you were only
about six months old when your mother
stayed along with you in the sod Hut
under 8 foot of snow while I moved to
herd 300 miles south to try and save it
saved about half of it you were a little
more than a year old at the time of the
great Comanche raids we stood off 500
Plains Indians for nine days petulant
Becky I think you better go on home see
the Ching gets those birds
Becky come here something my Allah tell
you
yes now's as good a time as any
they're gonna have every Young Buck west
of the Missouri around here trying to
marry you mostly because you're a
handsome filly but partly because I own
everything in this country from here to
there they'll think you're gonna inherit
it well you're not gonna leave most of
it to well to the nation really for a
park or no lumber middle cut down all
the trees for houses with leaky roofs
nobody will kill all a beaver for hats
for dudes their murder the Buffalo fur
robes what I'm gonna give you is a 500
cow spread on the Upper Green River well
that may not seem like much it's more
than we had your mother and I some votes
are gonna say I'm doing all this so I
can sit up in the hereafter and look
down on a park named after me I thought
I was disappointed in you didn't want
you to get all that money but the real
reason Becky is because I love you and I
want you and some young men to have what
I had cuz all the gold in the United
States Treasury all the harp music in
heaven can't equal what happens between
a man and a woman with all that growing
together I can't explain it any better
than that
daddy Becky when you're as old as I am
you'll thank me for this
dad long full grown I wasn't worried
about me I was thinking about you and
Mom
[Music]
well sir all three of them right out of
the carriage is getting rather late
Becky it's bedtime
mother he brought this he must have
intended to use it oh well well if you
you want me to gosh I haven't played for
me sure it's the rage now dev what are
you doing oh hi yeah I just thought I'd
get another cigar well you've got one in
your mouth and two burning in the tray
not move your cute baby's still and
softer than a mouse's ear
I want the whole wide world to hear
you're just right for me you're sweet oh
no not that rhythm do you know do it the
way they do with the plaza I know the
words
sure Becky will you sing with me of
course all right
[Music]
it's your move Oh Oh Deb you're playing
like an amateur let's call it an evening
I'd like know where your mind is tonight
[Music]
good boys like your father and your
embrace disappear to die like this
there's no disgrace
[Music]
for me well it's so good I kind of hate
to break this up but we're gonna have
that Indian hearing tomorrow morning sir
about our conversation earlier this
evening uh I believe I'd better
apologize yeah yes sir I've been
thinking it over and when I called you
reactionary well that's merely my
generations term for your generation is
nothing personal sir oh really oh good
night sir good night mrs. McLeish good
night and do come again tonight there
you go boss was a reactionary me yeah I
guess he says that anyone who wanted to
sell at a profit was a reactionary was
we reactionaries back in EM days when
you selling beef cattle for six cents a
pound on the hoof well are you arguing
with him
college boy
Devlin one more nephew is my kind of man
you wouldn't let some dude walk off with
the prettiest girl Western invert that
but I'm some kind of fight does it show
well what can I do I'm just one of her
father's employees I'm just a hired hand
around here every so often dev you spill
the strangest ideas everybody works for
somebody me I work for everybody in
these united states that steps into a
butcher shop for a t-bone steak and you
work for me there's not much difference
terrible thing just happen
Jr's horse ran away the one he rented at
the livery stable
tied up a rented horse by the range he's
probably back in a stall by now I think
we could get jr. something that he can
ride what I'd rather do daddy is Drive
jr. home in our barouche it's a lovely
evening and I'm sure uncle Drago
wouldn't mind driving
I would not got the kind of manners
don't keep me from saying so just to be
polite I'll Drive him home mr. McLintock
and you don't have to come this Becky
I'll see that he gets home safely I can
take care of myself you got yourself a
foot didn't you damn get the carriage
Drago
I'm going now you've got me wrangling
dude
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
miss Becky somebody better help me watch
the road you know I'm new around here
might take the wrong turn off
Devlin warned you no there isn't a
turnoff between here in town
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
daddy in my entire life I said what I
said and I'll stand by it to the debt
shoot him daddy shoot him at once why my
honor is at stake well now your honor
absolutely he improved my honor impugn
what does that mean
slander he slandered my honor he did I
said what I said and I'll stand by it to
the death he admits it see shoot him
well what is he admitting to he called
me up repeat the word I didn't
necessarily call you anything but I said
what I said and I'll stand by it to the
death well just for the tally books what
did you say I said that any girl would
permit a man to kiss her before they're
formally engaged is a trollop don't hold
on if you're my father if you love me
you'll shoot him well I'm your father
and I sure love you so you really shot
him hey if he dies he'll be the first
man ever killed with a blank cartridge
we use this to start the races on the
4th hey poor dear you'd have had me shot
in cold blood didn't happen yelling I
insulted you and all what you need is a
good spanking dad daddy beat me out of
this I think I'll give you what you
deserve you wouldn't dare wouldn't I
[Music]
you spanked my daughter damn you mean
you stood there while that brute beat
our daughter GW what's happened to you
in the last room are of Heller son that
you've always treated me like a squad
without subjecting dear sweet Becky do
this crude vulgar women are always
raising hell about one thing when it's
something else you're really sore about
don't you think it's about time you told
me what put the burr under your saddle
about me I don't intend to stand here
and hold a midnight conversation with an
intoxicated man
and I am not intoxicated yes
[Music]
yes sergeant
big McClintock we know you get us fair
judgment you general
follow me well Jake GW well GW it's been
a long time not long enough
Cuthbert your husband is a rude man yes
Cuthbert I know where your one-day
Indians mr. McLintock mr. McLintock is
not running this hearing sergeants eat
those Indians yes Jen be seated oh hi
hey I wanna come into town Rosie
lieutenant this hearing is now in
session
governor Cuthbert Humphreys presiding
good luck daddy Fred it's a plat court
government edict no braces as ordered
that the Comanche nation be transferred
from their present reservation to Fort
Sill it is the government's claim is
filed by Indian agent a guard at these
Chiefs after being released from prison
by a kindly government did that allows
and incite defiance among the tribe
against said order it seems gentlemen
that although some of these Chiefs speak
English Puma is quite at home in our
language they have chosen mr. McLintock
to be their spokesman I speak for the
Comanche rather I offer this translation
Rossi mr. McLintock
the Comanches say we are an old people
and a proud people when the white man
first came among us we were as many as
the grasses of the Prairie now we are
few but we are still proud for if a man
lose his pride manhood he is nothing you
tell us now that if we will let you send
us away to this place called Fort Sill
you will feed us and care for us let us
tell you this it is a Comanche law that
no chief ever eats unless first he sees
that the plots are full of meat in the
lodges of the widows and orphans it is
the Comanche way of life this that the
white man calls charity is a fine thing
for widows and orphans but no warrior
can accept it for if he does he is no
longer a man and when he is no longer a
man he is nothing better off dead you
say to the Comanche you are widows
norman's you are not men and we the
Comanche say we would rather be dead it
will not be a remembered fight when you
kill us because we are few now and have
few weapons but we will fight and we
will die Comanche thank you big
McLintock am i together the Comanche
defy the government of the United States
yes you may gather that the Comanche
defy the United States government or at
least this Commission
is the order of this court that these
Chiefs be incarcerated until such time
as detachment of United States cavalry
be made available to escort them and the
Comanche nation to Fort Sill this Court
is adjourned
Paul McClintock you are important chief
amongst these white people sway them
have them give us few guns to make the
fight worthwhile let us have one last
remembered fight for end of Komachi I
almost wish I could arrange that Puma
Hollande Nietzsche Oh hold on a job
sergeant yeah go man
it's sad these changing times it isn't
the times that are changing them
[Applause]
Thank You W family
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Bunnie
Oh our diva clinic
hey figured you'd be belly-down drunk
now
I've been doing some thinking drinking
bunny is that boxcar still on the siding
well sure but what I don't like it you
know they you figured they may need to
get out of there and lead the cavalry on
a wild goose chase that great white
father's gonna get nobody knows in he'll
investigate when they find out how that
side settled governor's been messing
things up they'll give those Indians a
fair trial
that's why I'm ammunition in that boxcar
you know what'll happen if they Indians
get some guns in their hands
somebody's gonna get hurt yes Pumas word
good enough for you but clinic you got
yourself a partner leave me out of this
Hema clinic
good night bunny good night governor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. McLintock oh there you are
mrs. Warren oh good evening I waited up
for you mr. McLintock 309 times straight
I think apartment 309 times straight
without a miss gotta be a record I
suppose so
mr. McLintock what I wanted to pounds
desk 6 inch brim 53 feet in the air it's
gotta be erected I'm sure it is but the
reason I was damn damn it woman can't
you hold that glass still of course sir
well down the hatch to my world's record
down the hatch yes sir and now to the
governor of our territory the governor
of the territory sir now don't you stick
up for a message one you're a fine woman
mrs. one but you'll certainly go down in
my estimation if you stick up for
Cuthbert H Humphrey governor of this
territory don't mean to change yes sir
well that Cuthbert H Humphrey governor
of our territory is a cult you know what
a call is man a call is a specimen that
is so worthless that you have to cut him
out of the her now if all the people in
the world were putting one hurt
Cuthbert is the one I would throw my
rope at at whom and whom I would throw
my rope at natural-born you call another
touch ma'am he knows her no I don't mind
if I do
good can't walk on one leg all I didn't
mean to be vulgar ma'am can't walk one
limb it's all right
sounds silly only a bird can walk on a
limb you know my wife her name's Kate
she insists on being called Katherine do
you know her
of course mr. McLintock and that's what
I wanted to well she thinks that
Cuthbert H Humphrey is panting for her
like a bull Buffalo at the first Greenup
of spring but what Cuthbert is panting
for is my money
don't make me feel like I'm drinking
alone ma'am
very well mr. McLintock if you insist
down that mr. McLintock I have something
very important to say to you very
important have to wait till morning
toodle Betty bye-bye
[Music]
this is Warren going on here now
Catherine are you going to believe what
you see or what I tell you mrs.
McLintock hope you won't misunderstand
it's the first hundred women sitting on
his lap that I misunderstood number 101
is quite simple
now GW McClintock is he's gone to sleep
just when I know exactly what I want to
say to him he goes to sleep I waited up
to talk to mr. McClintock I wanted to
tell him I was quitting you see sheriff
Lord has asked me to marry him and Oh
congratulations
I don't want to seem prudish but hey if
you are going to marry Sheriff Lord it
seems to me that you're sitting on the
wrong man's lap
[Music]
[Music]
wait a minute ladies till I catch my
breath and I'll get you up those stairs
as sure as my name is George Washington
McChrystal
[Music]
[Music]
you may be quitting mrs. Wallace mrs.
Ward but not tomorrow I want my
breakfast in bed
somebody sure put a knob on my skull
whose key are speaking Katie why mrs.
Warren was there
oh are you was there Oh whiskey bottle
was there and Katie's J for being what
Katie's ten for Israel yeah yeah Drago
old friend huh my wife does not
understand Drago I am sleeping in the
Dan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
come on get him aboard everybody ready
man number five needs a plank sit anyone
let us know when you're ready ladies and
gentlemen it is my honor to present to
you the governor of our territory
Humphrey Thank You mayor my friends and
citizens of this great territory this is
the ninth consecutive year it has been
my privilege and my pleasure to
inaugurate the McClintock fourth of July
celebration now the first event will be
the wild horse race but before I fire
this shot to start the event I would
like to say a few modest words regarding
my stewardship of his brain
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right professor Birnbaum now boys
you'll all know the rules it's fast
around the inside what's around the
outside first cowboy hits that finish
line without busting that egg is a
winner and I caution you boys about some
of them eggs go some eggs are last
year's holdovers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Catherine my dear you seem to be
enjoying yourself oh yes this is
wonderful it's the only thing I really
do enjoy about this barbaric country the
4th of July celebration
well captain I've been here for three
days I haven't heard from you is
anything wrong
Rach I just hope that it hasn't been
necessary for you to say anything to GW
what are you talking about
Catherine you see I'm in a rather
delicate position being governor of the
territory and all I just hope you
haven't found it necessary to say
anything about what about you and me
[Laughter]
pompous window do you think that you're
the only man who's ever tried to play
patty fingers with me who's ever tried
to lure me into the moonlight
well no but well I'm a big girl and I
can take care of myself my husband
nursed I can assure you governor but
your reputation is untarnished now get
out of my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we got a winner curly being disqualified
[Laughter]
you never believe what happened what you
smell a beer well naturally I'm drinking
beer between the two Bronco busting
champions of our territory
remember the AI Rome element wore your
garters to hold up my sleeves George
Washington McLintock you are a very
crude man well I guess so but that was a
rough horse like the jarred my insides
loose but it was worth it three years
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I guess so
nothing busted but my pride let are even
things up farmer for what well that sore
nose you gave me the other day well I
need what sore on him
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
the closing event is a table pony race
the finish line is it the barbecue so
start the Andrew Wow now what is that
false courage why you know what Douglas
doesn't ever use a thing like that I
want you to get on that horse get out in
front and stay out in front
I'll be out Fred that oh oh good boy
I remember stay out in front that I
command ons a good horse
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
about all the excitement keep one for
one fourth of July
Alma finally got his way but I reckon
he's riding out his last war party they
won't get very far
but one thing still has me puzzled where
did they get the guns I was wondering
the same thing my kidneys been bothering
me funny
GW what an idiotic joke joke do you
think that was a joke shop do you want
everybody in town to see me kill a
goodfeather I think they've gone yeah
what can I do nothin just like you've
always done
how long GW how long what tack she's
been riding herd on you for two years
now I'm a peaceable man
but my father used to say you raise your
voice it doesn't do any good it's time
to raise your hand well I've been
planning to do something about it online
I'll have another talk with her talk to
him talk to talking won't do any good
Becky have you seen him what's been
happening around here he's got hay all
over you did some mighty sneaky
goings-on here during that rate mr.
McLintock who was it said only a trollop
but gets a man before they were formerly
engaged oh but we are engaged sir you
are that is with your permission well
you've got it Oh mrs. warrens I think
it's wonderful I guess this is the only
engagement that ever started off of a
spanking mm-hmm I reckoned Birnbaum is
right all right Lord bless this is gonna
be a great day you contestants get ready
for the Cal Poly race who is it that's
me yeah not now are you insane I want to
talk to you
you have to wait I've taken all I'm
gonna take from you you are going to
tell me why you packed up picked up and
walked out on me
two years ago you remember you came home
from Jenny
[Music]
lipstick on my collar
[Music]
[Music]
TW you are a ruffian cuz Bert
you are right
[Music]
[Music]
I regret to inform you I've changed my
mind about matrimony
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is my you setting a new style
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I can fight all your water won't do any
good you've been digging those birds in
the me bird through here now your
competitor come up Thanks
[Music]
Oh keep it you may need it now get your
dessert
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no more living in the capital
no no more Newport in season nope no
more dancing at the Governor's Ball no
GW happy day three hundred and ten times
without a Miss that's a record
[Music]